cut this cushion he's like my friend was
shaking the tree catching The Sparrows
in the back like your friend
[Music]
all right do you guys remember not very
long ago there was this
um there was this teen who stabbed a
cheerleader 114 times yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know what's kind of crazy
though when you were saying this this
headline I thought it was just gonna be
really positive and I just wasn't
expecting to say stabbed a cheerleader
so that kind of been like less than 30
seconds I know your tone was just nice
sounding yeah it was like hey guys you
hear about this news you guys remember
hey do you guys remember the story that
we did that was [__] amazing
it was a cold dark night yeah yeah thank
you this is gonna be bad this is gonna
be bad race yourselves sponsor thank you
for a warning me dig into your memory
banks trying to find some people
thinking of your memory thanks you're
stupid yeah so she was brutally murdered
yeah it's brutal dude it's not like that
with that tone she was 13 years old her
name was Tristan Bailey
um and recently a Florida woman AKA his
mom the teen son's mom was uh she
pleaded to no contest to a charge of
evidence tampering in The Killing
because what she had done was washed his
jeans to get the blood out yeah she she
knew about that what does no contest
mean you could do that you're not
pleading guilty nor not guilty right
so
what is the court so her her and her
legal like positioning
they didn't know that it was like a
murderous thing they just they just
thought that he had blood on it or she
just thought he had blood so she was
trying to wash it off
[Music]
huh nah bro I bet you talked to that kid
for five minutes you're like this kid is
capable of murder yeah
is this like LeBron James in the middle
of a game putting the ball down it says
that's it
so did you lose what is this he's like
no contest
like children who murder people don't
try to wash the clothes just cut it up
in little pieces and throw the scissors
and the clothes away throw it away yeah
and like like Parts like a little bit
here a little bit you got a scatter
right yeah scattered all about or or
like um put it in lime and have it
disintegrate don't don't try to watch
how long would you need to put it in
lime for I don't know like based on the
documentaries I've seen it's usually
like a minute yeah but I don't know how
much time is a lasting documentary yeah
but you know but that is true though
like what kind of limes do you buy
this is this is interesting so when you
plead no contest
um it says like the reason for that is
there you could be viewed it in a
positive light so you might get a
lighter sentence but also you won't
there's no possibility of having to pay
civil damages
interesting is that like is that inverse
to like the idea of saying I'm not
guilty but then if you get tried and
charged yeah then it's just an absolute
a civil suit can follow oh because
you're depending on what happened yeah
interesting wow that's crazy that's so
it's like a money thing that's a sweet
little [__] I'm sure there's like a
million lawyers hate this guy for this
reason yeah is there another fourth plea
in the secret menu
not guilty I don't know some some
contest I don't know I just got here
we're just settling outside of court
right oh yeah it's only outside of Court
yeah because that is the amount of
settlements that happened outside of
court is like so much but even in those
situations it's not even a matter of
like guilty or not guilty sometimes or
right or wrong it's just like clean this
up and get it over with yeah the crazy
thing too is that you can settle out of
court mid-trial like the trial can
already be going and then it can be not
going well for someone and they can go
all right check it out and they'll do a
deal that makes sense that's crazy
um have you guys seen the movie
searching the one with John trout yeah
you're gonna say eraser yeah yeah oh
yeah I have seen that movie you have
seen it yeah yeah okay but because
you're the only one I don't want to do
any spoilers it's really good but no I
definitely won't watch it it's really
really won't watch it I think it was
made low budget the whole concept about
it sounds like it's an Asian Excellence
film and I hate those you know what
actually I'm just kidding I heard it's
really good though it's really good the
whole I thought it was too actually not
shot like a movie everything is done
through like webcam or like video camera
or stuff so it feels like it's like real
world FaceTime Zoom type stuff yeah
spoil it a little because I want to hear
a little bit Deborah Messing from Will
and Grace is in it oh spoiler now I've
sold okay how about I don't say anything
else about the movie but in context of
the article that'll spoil it okay
parallel them but the point is you know
what would you be willing to do for your
own child even in the face of guilt
enable them to be a murderer dude if you
find out your kid murder I don't know I
don't have a kid actually now I do uh I
have two of them yeah if two kids now if
I found out that my pugs killed another
human being you stupid I don't want
those pugs at all I'm like you know what
dude I can't have you in my house but
what if they come to you with the story
of like I was being attacked and I did
it that's why you gotta have dogs I
can't tell you no story I actually
talked to you I talked to Jill about
this and I have a weird stance on it oh
interesting what's your stance so to me
it depends on what was his intent yeah
and then uh
where where the where is this Morality
In My Spectrum okay so and you're on the
Spectrum so so if he was like if it was
like some Vengeance type [__] where I'm
Pro I'm in so he it's across the board
someone crossed his his [__] line
yeah and then he like kills the whole
family yeah then we're gonna try to like
go to another country and Escape because
I'm Pro Vengeance no disrespect yeah so
I'm like no contest a non-extradition
country but if he's [__] a psychopath
okay and then like you could tell us
marbles are loose and he kills the whole
family I'll probably shoot him I'm like
I I [__] I created something that is
like a parasite to society and I'm very
very sorry yeah wow that's kind of good
I'm very weird though I'll post this
question to you I kind of like that
there's telltale signs of uh of children
they may become serial killer when
they're when they're young like they'll
they'll kill animals and they'll play
with the dead animals they'll kill
if your child is exhibiting those things
and then you get him diagnosed him or
her diagnosed and then the the
psychiatrist like multiple psychiatrists
said this kid is a sociopath verging on
psychopathy and all that what do you do
as a parent at that point
probably gonna ask what the options are
yeah so what do we do now you know
because you know so it's a rainy day
Joe's outside there's snails and he's
[__] taking scissors
oh my God
he's just like oh there's the eye just
knocks them out you know me are you like
hey I need to go find Council I think
most kids there's some stores that Joe
tells where he's got a friend doing it
and I'm like there's no friend
cut this cushion he's like my friend was
shaking the tree catching The Sparrows
in the back like your friend huh
that's so funny you think he practices
like the my friend yeah so he doesn't
mess up dude if I want to blame
something on somebody I always go my
friend my friend did this and I was just
there tell your friend congrats on June
B Waikiki
hahaha
but like I think all kids mess around
with insects right they like they kill
insect stuff we're gonna say incest
like geez love incest come on is that
why you wear shades yeah yeah because
I'm I'm ashamed by it no but I think
kids like try to kill insects and bugs
and all that but then if you're like
dismembering cats or like house animals
like we gotta we gotta send you to a
shrink so I watched another Korean drama
that was on Netflix right called The
Glory I don't usually watch the ones
that are like two lovey-dovey Except
Nina makes me sometimes but there was
one that's about vengeance because I'm
also Pro Vengeance all Korean movies are
about vengeance by the way so this TV
show is called The Glory right this
girl's just like bullied like crazy and
stuff like that by this one bully this
chick and then uh when it gets I'm sure
you guys aren't really gonna watch it
but spoiler there's a moment where uh it
goes back to the past where she did kill
this girl that she bullied by like
lighting her like shirt on fire and then
when the girl's like oh my god get it
off you should like push it off the edge
of the building so she like Falls and
dies right but then it shows this moment
which ironically feels very human even
though it's like not relatable because I
haven't murdered anybody yet yeah
um she freaks out
and then she gets a call from her mom in
that moment and then she picks up she's
like oh my she starts like freaking out
she's like it wasn't my fault we were
just it was an accident blah blah she
starts just going off on like obviously
not the truth because when you're in
like a panic mode right like you said if
something happens I'm probably blaming
my friend or whatever you get kind of
get into this place you're doing
anything you can to it was actually I
swear like blah blah you know she just
fell and like I don't know what to do
right and then immediately well not
immediately there's like a moment of
pause because you could tell that the
mom's just thinking and then she's like
okay calm down just breathe did anybody
see you next get out of there right now
and she just kind of like
tells her daughter to like you know flee
that area and it's weirdly it's weirdly
related you think that's a good
parenting
I think I think that's relatable to try
to protect your own yeah that's what I'm
saying like that's your reflex right
because there's two perspectives to look
at this one is us on the outside looking
at it going oh judging the mom being
like okay I can't believe you're letting
your daughter get away with murder but
from the perspective of the mom or or
any parent a practical parent is you
want to protect your child to any
lengths yeah and you don't have all the
context you don't yeah you're either
gonna trust your kid yeah you don't see
the evidence of going on you don't know
where they're at you don't know where
the [__] cameras are you know you're
just kind of like all right like [__]
you calm down we'll figure this out one
time but you know you are trying to
protect them though do you think there
are parents out there that really truly
understand their children's behaviors
and like what they could be capable of I
think most no exactly right yeah that's
my point is like I think most parents
probably don't really know what their
kids are even capable of because I think
most parents aren't even self-aware
exactly they're not even on the same
Planet they don't even know about
themselves so for me I know who taika is
so like when he gets in trouble the
first thing I do is I punish him I'm
like probably your fault I don't care
what you say I've been pretty so he's
doing squats right away and then we
figure out what's going on but I think
most parents because they are they don't
even know who they are they definitely
don't know who their kid is yeah so
they're fighting for things without even
looking at Clues and they kind of just
let they might be like oh well my kid
would never do that but in reality again
bro he would have done that is what
happens a lot yeah right like I bet that
happens all the time they're probably
ignoring two signs that they know
because you don't it's like we're being
in denial about it yeah cause like you
know it's like you have an STD and then
you're like no but if I go to the doctor
it's only gonna confirm it yeah and then
so they just like people do that [__]
all the time yeah and then their penis
turns purple and scabby you know because
they didn't go to the doctor and then I
want to get offered and they're like
okay
he's like is that herpes under the lip
no like well I never go to the doctor's
I don't know yeah so it's not so it's
not herpes it's not is it something it's
a pimple actually yeah
I love these relatables contest would
you guys help your parent cover a murder
oh oh [__] that's dude it's okay I've
I've had this conversation with my
parents not about murder but about like
I thank them I thank my parents that you
haven't done it you're not doing
anything illegal right now at this age
and they looked at me like I'm stupid I
go and explain no because I just read an
article with this parent that's like
65-7 year old parent was doing illegal
stuff like tax evasion
um like money like laundering or
whatever and they got sent to prison so
imagine your parents being like 65 70 80
get sent to prison like this that's
crazy you know and so I I actually thank
my parents like thank you for not doing
anything yeah like illegal because
there's some parents that they don't
care they're like yeah I'm good I'm good
so like helping them cover it up because
I would think like my parents in prison
I probably would help them like cover
stuff I feel like technically if your
parents are Asian they're doing
something illegal
you know what I mean like how many like
oh I'm sure your parents like oh just
just pick cash don't bring me into this
you know and it's like why just pay man
so you could like that's a whole dry
cleaning business yeah not report all
the taxes at the dry cleaners with when
Bart said I think all Asian parents will
be illegal I'm seeing his parents like
murder people stabbing people 114 dying
we're talking about cash only businesses
yeah yeah we're talking about tax
evasion yeah that's technically illegal
but like if my parents are doing
something like that I'd be the best
person to help them get away with it
like I'd be like they're like oh yeah
wash the clothes no no no gotta cut up
in little pieces and then you'll get
limes and then put some salt and Tequila
the information is out there
I used to have freaking dreams that my
dad was like a murderer for some reason
I remember when I was a kid because he
was choking it with the belt probably
because because like I was just after
you were passing in and out I went to
the backyard one day and he was outside
the whole like wall was covered in blood
this is a real story I was a kid and I
was like what happened Dad and he goes
oh I was gutting it just got on the wall
and I was like what the
[__] was that fish on its period
I was just like I was like dude is my
dad a murderer like that's pretty cool
and then that's pretty cool he was out
there doing the same thing with his
friend and they were throwing fish at
the wall
but he didn't want to explain like he
was doing dumbass [__]
and I was like that's even cooler that's
my dad they were just going
because they they go they go fishing and
they just were throwing it oh my God
that's a different apparently I should
ever yeah the truth is way better